fired you this was our kicks cam tonight  i like that look right there that's  clean  i appreciate you i'm nice little sakai  action take off the glasses look back at  them  d wave like that look okay with this  toiletry bag i look like i'm about to  get 30. got the leaning spin  you got a toothbrush at least put it on  the tank top though  show off a little shoulder meat  very smooth and to my defense there's  nothing on yours  oh no they're just at these just oh just  something about that stuffy skit get it  okay that's with the smooth walk  i'm focused and uh guard your your eyes  searching fred flintz on baby yeah yeah  dead man  going back to the cave and look at that  you've heard of horsepower 90 000 points  got a lot of miles on them i don't  understand ambient d is fascinating but  the real question is shack smashing it  fat fast i love my feet my feet are hall  of fame feet first ballot i might add  first ballot hall of